once upon a time many years ago there
was a long terrible
[Music]
[Applause]
Dragon Quest Heroes 2 is a JRPG on
fast-forward the gradual addition of new
party members the rollout of plot twists
and other typical genre road markers
come at you at a fast clip if it
normally takes a hundred hours to amass
a kill count of ten thousand enemies
this game lets you reach such milestones
in less than ten and as one of the many
spin-offs of the 20 year old dynasty
Warriors series it retains the best
elements of the franchise's trademark
combat Dragon Quest Heroes 2
distinguishes itself from its equally
great predecessor with its free roam
friendly fields of battle which feels
like a homage to the open expanses of
mainline Dragon Quest games
[Music]
boxes
[Music]
unlike the first Dragon Quest heroes
this sequels premise doesn't involve the
brainwashing of once-friendly monsters
instead you're concerned with unexpected
invasions of neighboring kingdoms it is
when you embark on your journey to solve
the mystery of the warring lands that
you first realize how this game is
influenced by the wide open areas found
in many G RPG world maps - the random
encounters by reaching the other side of
these rolling battlefields you're
greeted with smaller but equally intense
war zones maps and conflicts that
resemble the story driven encounters
from the first Dragon Quest heroes
alternating between the larger spaces
and these more intimate combat zones
provides a level of gameplay variety
seldom seen in warriors games
[Music]
the events that unfold as you explore
these territories are rich in variety in
a given hour you could be navigating
through a labyrinth in swamp with
brain-teasing teleportation portals or
you could be hunting down a mischievous
shapeshifter impersonating townsfolk or
even your protagonist yes there are
straightforward objectives like taking
out bosses or escorting NPCs but the
game's exploration Focus G RPG inspired
segments avoid the tidy but boring
chapter base story progression common in
many subpar warriors anime spin-offs as
with every water spin-off this game
forgoes the exactness of stylistic
hacking slashers in favor of the
gratification of killing enemies on mass
this is and thanks to straight forward
controls we're stringing quick and
strong attacks into a single combo can
decimate two dozen enemies combat shows
further death with the return of minion
coins which temporarily add the monsters
you vanquish to your squad this form of
summoning loses some of its tower
defense inspired appeal from the last
game to make room for a wider array of
enemy powers including the immensely
satisfying ability to transform into
some of the game's larger enemies
developer Oh Megaforce wisely preserved
many of the previous game strengths
these include classic and simple
experience point driven character
progression gear upgrades and item
alchemy the biggest draw however are the
guest heroes from the main line dragon
quests
despite the strengths and appeal of the
game's original cadre of heroes they're
all skilled monster hunters although
some squad combinations are more
effective than others fan-favorite
turncoat for example is one of the few
teammates who can cast healing spells
which makes him valuable during the more
challenging battles experimenting with
different party formations is part of
the fun where you're compelled to
balance personal preference for certain
characters with team composition well
you do have to choose a main protagonist
among two heroes the ability to switch
to your other three party members
on-the-fly quadruples your potential at
effective damage dealing rotating
through your team in order to make the
most of their abilities and strengths
becomes its own game of micromanagement
this presents its share of challenges
and thrills depending on the current
battle predicaments of each squad mate
there wouldn't be this strong compulsion
to jump from body to body if not for the
modest contributions of your
ai-controlled buddies
[Music]
to experience a party's true ferocity
you would have to join real time friends
in the game's multiplayer modes a rarity
for warriors game when compared to
playing solo having friends along can
have a huge impact on your success rate
of battle optional multiplayer dungeons
are loaded with dragon quests meanest
foes and these ferocious welcome parties
change based on your level and team size
if you do come out on top in these
monster infested mazes you leave with
useful loot like a ball that temporarily
boosts the amount of XP you earn in
battle which can make your next play
session all the more smooth eg pneumonic
is Uni together get the caseta much like
its predecessor Dragon Quest Heroes 2 is
ensured of opportunities for high-volume
slaughter while effectively preserving
the charm of Dragon Quest a mega force
is thoughtful mix of familiar Dragon
Quest hero designs and new features not
only make the sequel engrossing but it
also shows the side series potential for
future installments Dragon Quest Heroes
2 makes for a satisfying hack and
slasher that is not only a great
warriors spin-off but is also a valid
gateway into this landmark G RPG series
I hope you're ready for this
[Music]